He is a famous dance move.
Please come on.
I know if the world's ready for that.
Okay.
It's just real small movements
in the knees. Handed the head.
Go Darling.
I am Jake Scott.
I am 27 years old and I am a musician
and I'm Rachel Scott.
I am 30 years old and I am
an actress and a writer.
Friends for five years, dating
four years, married two years,
two and a half.
Can you hear me?
I can read your lips.
I had just moved to la like five days
before and I got invited to go play
ultimate Frisbee.
I was totally going there thinking
I'm not going to meet a girl.
I just moved to this new city like
I have no plans for meeting girls.
And then I met Rachel and I was like,
oh crap,
this girl is something else.
It was made known to me by
all of her friends like, hey,
she's totally still into her ex boyfriend,
so just don't get your heartbroken.
And I was like, yeah, cool.
Thanks for the advice,
but I'm gonna I'm going to proceed
forward here because if I didn't try,
I knew that I would never
forgive myself for that.
It must have been a Saturday because
we were playing ultimate frisbee.
I had gone through a breakup in January.
We met in July. He stood out to me,
but I was like, I was not
on the market, so I was just
like, oh, this is a nice guy.
We started hanging out a lot. I
was like, I know who I'm marrying.
It's this other guy over here and also
I can't stop hanging out with Jake and
all my friends are like, okay, we get it.
You can stop telling us you don't like
Jake. Why do you keep bringing up Jake?
And I was like, yeah, I don't like
Jake. Okay. I don't like Jake.
But he was unlike anyone I had met and
our connection was unlike anything I had
met.
But that was confusing at first for me.
I said, we met at Frisbee. Me Too.
I said there was a lingering ex boyfriend
who is still occupying her affection
at the time.
Same. I mean how can we forget
that this was a drama for
so long story short,
I finally am done with ex boyfriend.
Tell him and then about
a month later I see Jake.
It was like a curtain had been
pulled back so he picks me up.
We go to Joan's on third,
we went to Joan's on third in studio
city cause we both love that place.
It's like our favorite
and I know that sounds crazy but I
remember sitting there thinking if I don't
marry this guy, I just really felt
at peace with him in that moment.
And then we wanted to hike. We were
there for a long time just talking.
I guess after that we would, back
to his apartment, we got Thai food.
I had bought this like behemoth
bottle of cheap red wine.
I was like trying to be smooth
and coolest stuff like that.
Then the bag just rips out from the
bottom of the bottle smashes. He cleans
it up, he gets us another
bottle of wine and I was,
I mean it was just like really showed
his heart the way he handled that very
small moment.
We went on a walk and we ended up with
this like hill where we overlooked la.
Okay, you're talking about Narnia.
Yeah. You did forgot about Narnia. Oh,
this is the best part of the date.
I actually couldn't hear anything.
It was in my hands doing
this. You did this and I was
like, oh my gosh. Narnia. No,
her name is where I knew
I loved Rachel will.
You knew before I knew that,
but that was like confirmation to me
cause it was like this is the most perfect
moment of my life.
I said at first I had made this weird,
silly commitment to myself that I was
only going to say I love you to a person.
When I knew I could follow up on it,
I want to mean it when I say it and
I want to only say it to one person.
Hopefully we went on a trip
with my family to Paris.
It was the last night at the trip, I had
written Rachel this really long letter.
And um,
I told her that I loved her for the
first time and I actually proposed at the
end of the letter. So I said, I love
you for the first time when I proposed
no, I think I might cry. Um, so he said,
I love you first and the reason it's
making me cries because I just had such a
history of like throwing my heart around.
And I had said,
I love you a million times.
And so to think that this whole time
there was some guy holding out to only say
it to one person and that I'm
that one person that's really,
um, amazing. I want it to mean it.
And I wanted to know that I could say
that and know that I had waited to say
that to one person than I knew I could be.
You would be the only
person I never say it to.
And you are the only person I've
ever said it to. No, I'm crying.
I always want to come across as perfect.
And so ultimately what that means is
sometimes I would hide things from her and
I wouldn't be honest,
I'd lie like making decisions on how to
manage money and there were times when I
would make some mistakes over here,
but then I would just be like, oh,
I'm going to take care of this.
I don't need to share this because
I'll take care of it, I'll handle it,
I'll handle it.
And I would hide things from her until
ultimately I couldn't hide him anymore.
Seeing Rachel's face when
she found out that I was
lying to her about anything,
it's just like the most heartbreaking
thing I've had to go through.
Hell man.
Being in a relationship where I'm
truly vulnerable for the first time,
I think with that comes out
the best and the worst of you.
And when I'm sad or feel
I cover it with anger,
I can get so mad and then I'll be
mad at him and I'll be aware of like,
oh, this is whatever I'm angry
at isn't really his fault.
But it's hard to let go of anger in those
moments because what I'll do is I'll
go out in the world and give my best to
everyone else and then come home and be
exhausted and if something's gone wrong
in my day, I'll take it out on him.
If that happens enough,
you know,
it's affects him and so it really makes
you start dealing with your stuff that
you've kind of put away in corners and
not dealt with or made excuses for.
The consequences of my actions
now don't just affect me.
They affect you too. And it's made
me grow up in a lot of ways. Yeah.
If you would look on paper at the
things that we've gone through,
like we haven't had like any
traumatic event happened to us,
but like being so connected,
like your souls are connected,
you don't just wake up knowing how
to do that the right way. You know,
Andy,
you come into marriage typically thinking
you're doing well and then it exposes
all these things in the relationship.
And so I think to have a
healthy relationship you have
to be healthy individuals
through getting healthy on our own.
The marriage and turn becomes healthier.
Yeah.
I love how Rachel feels so
passionately about everything.
She sees the beauty in humanity and in
the world and it is such a joy to have
her in my life because it makes me see
the beauty and everything like in just
little things that I would just walk past
and never think about. Like she just,
she feels, it's so deeply, she's
like the color and my world.
Like you are so much better
than I could've ever dreamed
and you honestly make
me such a better man.
Yeah.
I am super up and down.
I feel a lot and he is so steady
and he's also really taught me about
vulnerability and intimacy because again,
I had so many past relationships where
I was never truly intimate or truly
vulnerable is just given me a safe
place to be myself and to actually be
intimate and vulnerable with someone.
You really are everything to me.
So I was going to say,
you are my world and I'm truly
would be in shambles without you.
I have no idea.
I'd probably be dead in a ditch somewhere.
Farmer in Ohio,
Ohio is great,
but you know, it's hard for me
to talk about the way I feel,
but I really do love you and you
are truly the only person for me,
like really?
If you left or died,
I would just be happily single because
you are the only person I want to be
with.
I really am so thankful for you.
Let me do
it's breakfast
together while she's sleeping
in your high school sweater.
Never seen anything better.
It's the season three.
You watch
evening or
your best friend.
Oh, it's snow. Just
picture perfect. Dad. Why?
No, just a rainy. Nothing stops fine.
Yeah. Snatch his highs
and lows. Champagne toast.
Calm to know those not on
purpose to Tuesday.
Yeah.
Tuesday.